the Joe Rogan experience look at where
they were in 2014 look where they are
now with faking the Chris Cuomo thing
they've they've that's his idea the the
Chris Cuomo know pretty gross did you
hear what he said on his radio show know
what he said he said I don't find value
in what I do I think it's ridiculous he
said I don't like what I do for a living
I don't like you patient I think you
know and then he said something
defective I'll never beat them in
reference to like Hannity and Maddow or
something like that I think in my prism
in ratings yeah and ratings so he's
their biggest show he is I'm pretty sure
Cuomo is their biggest show yeah this is
the only one that seems to be a man and
he doesn't crack a million in the
ratings really yeah it's like eight and
I think it's like 800 to 900 I think he
periodically might the ratings might be
going up I could be wrong so check the
latest stats but I hear something happen
I think that the CEO producers went to
him and said look man you got this thing
like we should we should we should run
with it let's like go to your house
we'll film it well make it this big deal
I think so and I think it wasn't that
bad I think he had mild symptoms look
the dude went out the guy left his home
he was you know when he was talking
about the the issues he was having he
was he seemed normal right like here's
what I would expect from someone who is
as sick as he seemed to be I don't feel
that good but hey I'm one of the lucky
ones no he's totally normal
yeah that's what I would expect he's
saying he's shivering so hard he's
chipping his teeth it seems ridiculous
yeah that would seem I don't know I mean
maybe when it's night time and you're
tired because one of the things I
remember
last time I was sick was quite a while
ago at the end of the night I'd be like
really a key because I was tired and I
was as I was tired my immune system
would be depleted and then I would feel
the effects of the cold more and then
you wake up in the morning you feel a
lot better maybe pop some ibuprofen I
know he's taken Tylenol so I'm not
supposed to take ibuprofen for this for
some reason well he said I think he was
taking some Michael yo said that he was
told to take ibuprofen and when he did
it made it way worse no yeah well so so
here's here's what can I say I'm not
gonna accuse the guy a lot of people are
penny and everything got sick I don't
think that's the case he probably got
sick he tested positive but right I
think he it seemed fairly mild in
comparison to other people like Michael
yo when I talked to him
well first of all when he was doing a
video talking about recovering from it
was coughing yeah and in the video he
was coughing when he was talking about
our Instagram thanking everybody but he
had a bad case of it where he got
pneumonia and it was rough and you know
Michael's a healthy guy so that was
disturbing to me but the Chris Cuomo
version of coronavirus didn't seem that
scary
the dude wasn't quarantined okay he went
out to some property 30 minutes from his
home presumably with his family he was
witnessed by somebody else not supposed
to do that right no you're not I mean
it's not just that but on CNN they said
he was locked down right they did this
whole reveal where he comes out of the
basement so I've been waiting for this
do a tick-tock dance with his daughters
I don't know I think he did but I think
the reason he went on his show
complaining was because the movie was
coming the producers told him to do this
fake thing and he didn't want to do it
he want you right look man I worked when
I make sense he can't call them out cuz
he wants to keep the job when I worked
for you know one of these companies they
told me to side with the audience we
talked about it last time I was here
mm-hmm
they wanted me to create a narrative
that the audience agreed with because we
were there to serve them what was the
narrative young progressives whatever
they say
so social justice so whatever young
progressives say gonna side with that
and I told him I asked are you saying
that if there's a factual news story
that would be upsetting to audience we
won't cover it they said I think that's
fair yeah
[Applause]